[Music]
we've got a few big things massive this
week we're going to treat everyone with
the love and compassion that they
deserve all week yeah welcome to YouTube
a loving compassionate community love
island sex peninsula I'm just thinking
of spin-offs I've never watched it but
everyone's banging on about [__]
Mountain and we do for an event
[__] Internet sure who-who's I guess
we've gotta cover it let's meet a lot of
people desperately famous first thing
I've noticed whoa
Sint Lady Gaga she wasn't born this way
those are ridiculous
yeah right
Michael you one day Thomas you know that
Tyson theories brother Kidd little
brother Wow
Tommy Fury's the name love Islands the
game is the goal of this short to piss
you off yes find someone and [__] them
and then win ashore yeah so the winners
are the ones that pair up and manage to
leave the island is sort of cool yeah
[__] in arms almost two years looks at
personality-wise I'd say I'm a ten I
would say a humble nine but being a hero
kind of pumps me up to that test we
respect our fire firefighters in the UK
they put their lives on the line to save
others I respect any firefighter
watching this or I look at him and say
[__] he's a cop you know get a [__] so
my type of girl I'm not really that
fussy looks twice as long as I have that
initial attraction [__] off are you not
that fussy I'm not that fussy looks-wise
as long as I've got that initial
attraction [__] off if I could be what
I'm like with the boys around them and
they'd actually like me for it I'll
stick a ring on it
when I'm gonna get them married you know
I look over I think stick a ring on that
object brilliant
what's that burn stuck a ring on it
didn't I yeah awesome notice and just a
mediocre face yeah yeah no problem I've
marry a corpse there is 70% of me which
is an old man in a young person's body
he's got a saggy dick balls and dick you
look at him he think normal-ish that I
was gone for that of
yeah only why he looks exactly am i
Kaali why all these a bit of an old
I know he's an old man in the middle
yeah I like 50s 60s music absolutely
love it in fact yeah
can I just say one thing if you like old
music it doesn't make you old I like
Beethoven I don't say I'm 200 years old
mate all right you wouldn't understand
him he's complex yeah I like Celtic
chanting Bryan's maybe 2,000 years old
he's trying to say is he's different he
stands out yeah he's on the thing going
on in many ways I'm elvish at heart
because I really love the Lord of the
Rings music not the way it works I'd
like to think I'm the full package from
the waist though that's not a compliment
to yourself
I'm the full package from that what
you're saying is you're all dead [__]
you're all dick
might be about a pail of bark and [__]
goods or subscribe myself in three words
can't can't come funny honest funny
bubbly bubbly energetic sassy and bit of
a diva you know people who call
themselves sassy in a bit but either
instant trouble I'm a [__] but I think
I'm good-looking enough to get away with
it yeah well you're wrong I'll treat
people like [__] in time for tea and my
look start to fade and then I won't
understand it anymore I'm a diva no
you're an [__] is what you mean
you're horrible to people and then when
they don't react well you go well sorry
if you can't handle my sassy personality
no one wants to come need when someone
goes oh I don't really like her you go I
hate people [__] you're not bitching
about you they're stating a fact I hate
people who don't like me yeah because
you're an [__]
the user leah has had nude pictures of
her breasts released by GQ magazine they
didn't release them but they took the
pictures and somehow they've made their
way onto the internet she's not a happy
bunny today I'm a ball of negative
emotional hole
I feel blindsided embarrass violated
angry sad and a million other things
possibly happy not solely because I did
not consent to this but also because of
the vile way people have reacted and bad
bad bad vile whoo it's important to me
that someone actually be held
accountable for their actions and the
way it impacts my life now you're saying
or other people saying hey but we've
seen all your other bloody nudes and
your boobs and you you know when you put
it out there it's been fine but she does
look good but
it's not the point she should have
thought in the option to put out what
she wants I get that but if you post a
shitload of revealing pictures of
yourself including ones where if you're
wearing see-through tops your tits oh
you're constantly putting that out there
then eventually the world is not going
to see your body
there's a [__] temple eventually
they're gonna see you as Fang him you're
constantly [__] revealing right
anyway and people are just gonna be like
saying he's he's tits no big deal
especially blink-182 album piggies tits
if it was Jennifer Lopez or Beyonce or
Britney Spears where they've been very
limited on what they've released on a
long career in their bodies are not just
out then it would be big news but this
is just the reason it's becoming big
news is because she's reacting the witan
blowing and it just so happened to come
out the day before her album or whatever
she did it that's inconvenient it also
happens the photos are actually quite
good photo looks unbelievable all right
okay in my opinion I mean you know the
album does well yeah I respect her right
did not have this release but just puts
on the show you sell it if I posted
loads of topless pictures and someone
else released another another one of me
where I'm on a beach somewhere then I
can't really complain the horses bolted
yeah saying that giant boob horse is
halfway down the play titties as some of
you have probably already heard ksi and
edgy are beefing again a G's made a
video accusing gifs and things and
deadly now has been keen and subscribers
for the first time in a long time and JJ
is actually losing subscribers so one of
his friends really cooling my channel
name a dead YouTube channel edgy I
didn't appreciates it
considering I'm not friends with the guy
really I spent time in America with him
but I didn't see him as a friend but he
was close to my brother so I considered
him somewhat family you know a friend
you're my family
you know a friend you're my cousin yeah
you're a brother we haven't got 45
minutes once What did he say he
basically says JJ bullied me in videos
it was kind of a brother dynamic older
brother younger brother dynamic I'm not
saying it's a healthy dynamic but it's a
dynamic we see in a lot of relationships
to Allah and Deji looked like he was
alright with it at the time he was sort
of playing along but now in retrospect
daddy's not happy with that
he's they're not happy about JJ sleeping
with a girl that he liked because in
many ways it sounds a bit like Deji
saying I had dibs happens with women if
men like them right they choose who they
want to sleep with and then they sleep
with them right and sometimes we've just
got to live with those decisions yeah
and you can't own a woman you don't go
hey that one's mine in the last month
he's got less than a million views for
the most part yeah the whole time and
then he goes from insulting JJ 7.2
million he's gone too far two points up
the cliques are coming and he's about to
hit ten million subscribers when he's
been stuck on 18.7 for what seems like
eternity if he hasn't done it four
clicks then that's unfortunate I mean it
some portion of him it's just I mean
like him yeah this must be a living
nightmare for him what I would say is I
do feel very sorry for him in the sense
that he's there's something called a
pain pattern that he seems to be trapped
in and he just does the same thing over
and over and over again doesn't quite
know how to break it and that would
annoy me if I was around him because I
think you're better than this sometimes
look at well doing anyway you think dad
she's being manipulative - yes but I
don't know if daddy knows he's being
deliberate no drink every time he says
thank you I wanna start off this video
by saying thank you all of you for your
support
or your emails where you'll tweet or
your Instagram DMS everything thank you
so much for your support such a
politician I love it he's the Donald
Trump of YouTube right now I think he's
more like the Ed Miliband it's like it's
all wrong it seems like a lot of you for
going through like the same issue that I
was going through and it seems that I
opened your eyes Oh pasta you've opened
my eyes dev all be gone he really feels
like he's expose Jo Jo yeah and he feels
like he's worse but everyone who's
supporting me all of you I want to say
thank you so much the support is
overwhelming
this is him feeding into people like you
said time you tell me if it's smart it's
not
thank you that's smart though what he's
saying is you're on the right side well
now I feel like he could start his own
version of like Scientology Deji I think
people would actually buy into it as
well damn ontology emails you know
saying that you're the exact same thing
what does these immune cells and I've
got 10 million subscribers my brother's
got 20 million he keep [__] the girls
out what that's a weird email I have an
equivalent situation but inside
career how can anyone relate to this I
just want to say all of you people thank
you so much I've received a lot of
emails I'll probably say over 100,000
people don't care that much about the
climate
maybe someone spelling it one letter at
a time and sending email I'm pretty sure
he read the first few emails in his
inbox and thought yeah shitless and then
he looked at the number and the rest
were just like have you got finance and
[__] like that is regular bit he's like
100,000 kept turning to his dad and
going there's a Nigerian prince here on
to give his money thank you so much only
that this should be a thing smile about
for him even if he is winning the war
against his brother I see it from his
perspective he thinks he's the good guy
in this he thinks he's Batman not a
single person on this planet has helped
daddy's life more than juju not one
person misses islet ng no but like not
one person because this is a serious
situation and he's treating it like
you're uploading on your YouTube channel
instead of getting in direct contact so
truly who's got his phone number you can
take the seriously phrases the deadly
one of heard on comedyshortsgamer in
quite some time
whatever anyone said to be something
funny I want a little video I could send
them through that lull and haha it was
it was literally to bring it show him
awareness as well how he's been treating
me you want to talk about maturity you
want to talk about being a man act like
a man
dad G has fought in front of thousands
of people you've done things which
required courage before approach your
brother man-to-man when there's no one
else in the [__] room and have this
out talk it out if you're literally
saying that this isn't for views there's
a bull [__] have the courage to go man a
man and a Lea difference is out when
there's no one else in the [__] room
not telling the world on him not telling
mom and dad on him just go to each other
and have the chart and get it over and
done with the best thing my Jade you can
do in the situation is like that just
get one on one with this guy or never
refer to it ever again youtuber Jake
Paul sparks backlash as he advertises
for intern that will be paid it's fun
I've seen in an interview this guy
wanted to be the doctor tray I'll be you
to that
you got rich to peer them in fun dr. Dre
often when 50 cent would turn up to the
studio ago I can give you 50% fun from
this album yeah and 50 when absolutely
if you're a young aspiring music
producer and engineer please read we're
in need of a full-time in-house producer
slash engineer who will mainly act as an
engineer for us acting as an engineer
this will be an internship position and
will provide you with real life
experience connections exposure and a
whole lot of fun scuse me are you a
sound engineer yes how much fun can we
pay you in why are you getting in term
and you can definitely afford to pay
that chick does some country [__] and
such as one of those things isn't it I'm
sort of disappointed in Rovin can we pay
you same fun okay I'll give you 200 fun
can we hire maybe you could pair in dick
that's not legal prostitution no you
can't don't even inquire it looks back
make sure okay guys this episode of true
news is sponsored by expressvpn Wow well
you want to be anonymous online Brian
sometimes like it's like when you're
around your home you want everyone to
know you have nothing to hide in your
house but you want everyone looking in
mm-hmm I get what you're saying yeah but
worried why people need to do this well
because some people want privacy online
and they work well free but also what
are you being looking up what you being
googling probably not stuff nearly as
bad as you that's the problem yeah yeah
you look at terrible stuff on that which
I believe it's perfectly legal
yeah but there's some times where you
just want to order something then you
just think probably don't want anyone to
know I've ordered that right like a
colander for your mum just something
where you can sort of use it for a good
time right okay a blog that linkle
really doesn't even bounce around and
not all the best times now the thing is
Brian would you want hackers would you
even want your own mum to know what
you're going on online exactly know so
she can do yeah well she would if she'd
seen well turn on yes so if you got
expelled not to record sometimes do lose
my laptop or something and you don't
want her sort of logging in looking to
history so you I need expressvpn so if
you say wanted to use Express VPN and
have some privacy online can we serve
some privacy please yeah let me just
order my blow-up Adlon pool and peace
sure or
say I wanted to hide the fact I was
getting a holiday for us together to go
somewhere you know yeah well expressvpn
calm forward-slash Geordie
that's expressvpn calm for / Geordie for
three months free with a one-year that
one can ever see just how [__] up you
are three months free with a one-year
package it's well worth and of course if
you wanna support true news this is the
way to do it because we rely on people
like expressvpn in order to get this
done plug Express we otherwise we die
leaving the news moving on to pop
culture here's three ways Brian are
three common mistakes made in a street
fight this is a man who runs three
successful businesses but apparently not
on a treadmill
good good good guys top very good thank
I said thank you same mistake number one
in a street fight thinking it's going to
be a fair fight sometimes you're walking
down the street someone trying to rob
you someone try to pour a weapon on you
someone or maybe and in a bar you're
walking down at night in the street
especially also the ladies I haven't
seen what he knows martial art wise yeah
it's probably [__] although one
thing I would say we're looking at a
fraud I'm not sure if this man's
business relies on his communication
skills they might do something like this
oh that's a good point literally didn't
give me that's not funny yeah that's not
fun good hard all this change yeah no
you take the change yeah so it's not a
fair fight how do you know they don't
have a weapon how do you know they don't
have a gun how do you know they don't
have their friends and how and also the
situation in the street what if it's
raining what if it's sunny what if it's
snowing
how do you know if it's raining if it's
sunny if the end of your outdoor how do
you know those things you know life is
unpredictable it's a good point I went
out in shorts in it rain he might be a
very good fighter this excuse me 1020
years of a vengeance is a martial artist
he's explained at you how a knife gives
you an advantage in the fight honestly
Joe Rogan's watch out his dick number
two what do you think it's gonna be I
think it's gonna be wear shoes you don't
wear enough shoes by not fighting all
right right you're not wearing clothes
or really basic things so there it's
gotta be something like it's not a way
if you catalyst something right you give
the attacker the signal that you want to
fight house
what signal am i giving I want to know
what the signals are Brian I'd love to
know what the signals are here we go the
minute you put up your hand what does
that tell you
you are fight yeah I'm ready to go I'm
ready to explode from here Wow my
special smooth criminal
some of you Michael Jackson Elvis don't
give any verbal warning the dumbest hey
what what what what what what man what
the [__] man he's watched a lot of
American movies hasn't he a lot of
Rompin yeah he's watched die hard just
too many you what man what you gonna do
the first point is they might have a
knife they might have a gun it's not
fair they might be in the snow the rain
the Sun night and day when you don't
know what's coming sucker punch them you
be unpredictable yourself they're gonna
be unpredictable you be unpredictable
yeah six and a half minutes that's what
we've got the other tip within that
point is even when you don't know if
someone wants to fight or not
punch them yeah all right that's often
my advice right first yeah exactly
old woman approaches you you tell me the
wreckage - I hover naive she's down all
right that woman is dead on the floor
but you are safe die old woman yes guys
just spouting [__] right and it's all
partly true you could do this video if
you knew nothing about fighting yeah I
want to see what other [__] this guy
does he must be an absolute [__] no
he must be an amazing person how to
develop self-awareness Wow how do you
develop self-awareness knowing yourself
ultimately all knowledge means
self-knowledge how is this guy so
[__] rich knowledge me self-knowledge
I love he goes it's all about
self-awareness here's five pictures of
my Bentley so how do you actually
develop self-awareness I believe there
are two main ways to do it number one
you could do it in a way where when
you've gone through a lot of hardships a
lot of struggles I'm literally having a
great life I've been being born a
wonderful family we the family had money
doing pretty good
well things are going good I want to
know what business to invest in Laurens
help me find out no no no Brian strong
you've got a [__] you life um you've
gotta go and take a lot of drugs you've
got to lose your job you've gotta end up
getting evicted from the house cinefacts
in order for you to find self-awareness
right after the comedies do that right
strong game right yeah and there are a
lot of different personality tests out
there right even like strength finders
what are your strengths what are you
what are you good at what are your
weaknesses what are you not good at
Donald Trump he is Donald Trump they
discard your space in general isms every
time amazing how I've never known
someone speak so long and say so little
we just watched a cheese video I might
be little old now but honest what snake
it was dropkick by a guy yeah I think if
they show the other angle later in the
report yes she doesn't look all that
bothered by column the used to call him
the orc yeah and you can see why the
[__] is built he at 71 took a
drop kick to the back and moved to set
don't let me wrong the technique on that
dropkick was [__] shambolic although
most people couldn't even get to that
point Arnie
one of the most good guys I think he's
good in a lot of ways some questionable
politics but I'm taking double use for
forever money's a winner I've sent this
this man sings a song just too many
different tunes let me know if you like
the song
[Music]
[Applause]
look do you know what I would think if I
was here
why are you thinking him another man
sucking dick have you seen this yet no
this is steve-o climbing up a massive
crane in an attempt to sort of a protest
against SeaWorld
[Music]
I really respect him for this I think
he's hot in the right place but also
we've got a fire and you know there in
probably an ambulance and cops who
probably should be doing like proper
work yeah where people are actually like
in need
oh yeah so he's definitely killed at
least five six yeah I think he's
speaking out on the right thing yeah
just crazy bad what question would you
ask wild man if you could Brad that's
right can you wank in prison I
personally say is when you do [__]
got sick and you're going up the hole so
he's all about this ability to get in
prison you're going the whole lockdown
bit of privacy there's only you in the
cell she'll really think in memories I
love how casually these guys discuss a
hard life in prison as if it's just like
I'm out caught bought myself a six-pack
straight that sell a head count so if
you could time your way into under 30
minutes just the casual way he's sort of
sitting a journalist I just like they
were shot inside of a session one yeah
two middle-aged men sitting on a couch
telling young people how they they went
you've got to keep it under 30 minutes
guys you gotta love these two like you
just have to love these guys have you
ever seen 50 cent but dating your mum
family freaks out when I meet them for
the first time so I thought I have some
fun with that but this time I'll try
something new your mom you know I wanted
to talk to you on something
oh the anomalies you said the mums in on
this no but that you think this is real
because these always seem like really
bad I didn't jobs tell me what you think
I wanted to tell you that back in high
school
I was thinking with this guy and move
actually involved Curtis would you come
out here me Georgie please this is face
like these kids faces that he walks out
such a joker isn't he he's evil evil
yeah we got him is really fun Cameron
young book to this day oh yeah to this
day when women I've dated have
introduced me to their families yeah
especially dads mm-hmm they're no longer
able to a much and their daughters as
they're sort of innocent little daughter
they're looking at me like there's no
way this guy's like you know not ruining
it this is called death stranding I want
to know whether you're sort of into it I
think we should get into reviewing video
games just to get people to send for
them for free
that's [__] terrifying
no an eyes waking up yeah it looks very
Metal Gear exactly which is why I
thought you'd like it but instead of
being just military you have to deal
with ghosts and spirits and those kind
of things nor BB at all at home I'm
excited you then get put in a forest
where there are demons but you cannot
see them you can only see them moving
pretty scary there that's where they all
are but then they disappear
Wow how freakin intense is that look
yeah anyway there's like loads
characters loads of really famous actors
in here it looks pretty good I mean come
November the 8th well no okay Brian we
don't need you anymore now we don't need
you anymore we can get a robot to do all
the things and say all the things they
just want where their silly clothes now
shut up because look they just need one
picture of you present a system that can
learn realistic talking-head models
notably learning of a new head model
requires just a handful of images in
this example the model was learned from
8 frames 8 frames Brian that's not even
a second of footage imagine like where
they'll be of 10 years yeah you will not
know whether you've said something or
it's a will any trick video where it's
like we pretended to be Brian on if
anyone accuses me of anything then there
you go
yeah yeah pretty much the robots you
pull the fake out as Kanye West says oh
yeah I thought I thought you'd want to
see this so Brian you're waiting days
going well what do you immediately think
to do that's right Brian skateboard down
the street oh no it's you shouldn't be
doing that in a dress doll oh no oh oh
no this is bad
no just fall face-first there as well oh
she looks terrible
he looks like an idiot there yeah I got
more on him on his skateboard on her
wedding day instead of getting in the
car like a sensible person he said
something whacky and cookie and be
different everyone wants to be different
these days
and sometimes when you try and be
different and it's stupid you fall flat
on your face on the best day of your
life and you ruin it let me show you see
that golden buzzer if you go but you see
that there was a kid with autism a blind
oh yeah hey sings yeah I mean I'm sure
you've all seen it I was like almost in
tears and almost cried I'm not a [__]
soft [__] right so I held it in like a
man the schools are these
Robert Bakewell primary school I'll let
you through Mike thank you
no worries house alright make nice and
friendly I am he's recording himself
driving around a school right we don't
want to do that so I'm coming towards
McDonald's now on bars be Road and start
the video again mate so I'm a bit
disappointed Kitty hasn't seen me oh I
haven't seen kitty searching for cars I
don't know what was he doing who are
these conceptual people I think someone
threatened him and said don't come round
bars be roads and then he went and
filmed himself there oh so that's what
this is about this is a hard man flexi
when I came to your ends you did nothing
this money just flexing I like whiskey
like all kinds of whiskeys
and then I found out this this whiskey
was out I thought right I've got to do
it so as you've read from the title it's
got a knife now oh my god that guy
earlier warned us at any moment the
person could just pull out a knife but
looking we're never seen a comedy yeah
you need a yep that looks absolutely
stunning that looks a real nice golden
rich whisky try it m8 you like dark I
wanted to thicker to me it was no I
agree
have we got any proper 12 there'll be
two votes all over them do you want to
sit with him oh yeah [__] it
oh yeah actually then I remember it and
the other vanilla you can definitely but
I like the vanilla how much you want
just a little shot of it yeah just
enough it took me till till I'm older
yeah - appreciate whiskies yeah I never
really enjoyed it you your dad seems to
educated you on that [__] I think it's
like my family are all whiskey man
they're good men kiss
you're getting the wood come through the
toast of wood you getting lots of
vanilla well you just gave the sweetness
of the honey you are getting that honey
aren't you you do get the vanilla he's
right
his review is correct June would you
like to try a sip and give your verdict
to the public it's nice isn't it it's
nice and smooth
it's got a bit of a burr doesn't it all
whiskies two of us yeah but it's not
really love is you've got a very
cultured hand he does this a lot and you
really know what he means when he does
this his hands are really expressive
this is just a nice smooth whisky is
that is really really good this man is
becoming a real food room what is your
favorite mixer was with apple juice
since you tried that with me
mm-hm you know our trip to Monaco if you
haven't seen it to check it out on the
channel now where we drive along the
apple juice really does go down well
with yeah amazing apple juice is a great
mixer with most alcohol don't have any
unfortunately no some berries me so I
call that into a Hammonds no I think
that's quite enough
I love leave that man yeah he's just a
great guy go over drink with him on the
channel if you're avail did you lot
chose to to the true news fans and those
of you that watch to hate see ya